where do we go from here because the
democrats are going to keep licking
their wounds here i mean they were
already setting this up
earlier they said look there's no way
we're going to get a fair trial here
this is all going to be run horribly
eric swalwell former future president
eric swalwell
who is me and you and everybody else
according to his campaign
he said that god could have been called
as a witness republicans still wouldn't
have listened
the choice was well do we chase those
people
not knowing what they're going to say to
the courts for
years or do we go forward with a
powerful thundering case that we have
and also knowing that mitch mcconnell
was already telling us that
he believed the challenge was a
jurisdictional one so we could have
called god herself
and the republicans weren't going to be
willing to convict so we're proud of the
case we put forward
[Music]
god herself did you hear that wow
zing oh eric so edgy
by the way whatever happened to
respecting people's preferred pronouns
god has been very clear about his
preferred pronouns
he goes by father he is incarnate in
jesus christ the second person of the
trinity
the third person of the trinity is the
bond of love between the father and the
son
goes by he and him throughout the entire
bible
now eric swalwell oh he's going to be
very insistent that we call caitlyn
jenner she
but god goes by herself now this is not
just
a glib comment i mean i suppose for
eric's well well it is a glib comment
but you can read something a little bit
deeper here
which is that what the left is seeking
to do ultimately
is to upend the whole society this is a
simple point it almost doesn't even need
to be said
but i i i want to highlight it now
because we're being told republicans are
upending the constitutional order they
have no respect for democracy in our
political traditions
give me a break give me the only people
in this country who are trying in any
way or desire in any way to uphold our
political traditions
are the republicans are the
conservatives the left hates this stuff
they're trying to upend our entire
language they're trying to upend
our social institutions they're trying
to upend the way the way the government
is run
they're trying to upend even the family
the bedrock political institution
and they're trying to upend our
religious principle too not just the
politics not just the culture but even
the religion
to invert the character and identity of
god
eric swalwell could not tell you that's
what he's doing he can't tell you a
whole lot but that is what he's doing
and that is the implication of so much
of what these
democrats and the left broadly are up to
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts